Aww yeah, today we're going to learn
English with a beautiful song by the
iconic band Bob Marley & The Wailers,
Redemption song.
Won't you help to sing
these songs of freedom?
'Cause all I'll ever have
Redemption songs.
Now, many people find this song extremely
inspiring and we can find amazing covers
by talented artists like Rihanna, Beyonce,
Eddie Vedder and John Legend
And by the way, if you're new
here then I wanted to invite
you to hit that subscribe button and the
bell down below because every week we
make learning fun with your favorite
series, songs and more so that you can
understand fast speaking natives without
getting lost, without missing the jokes
and without subtitles.
Like Thi Cam who says that
she's not only learning new
Hey, real quick, do you want to master a native pronunciation, vocabulary and even grammar?
Well, the most fun way to do it
is with our Fluent with Friends
course and today you can try it for free
with our three-part masterclass, so I
want to give you three reasons why you
should try out this three-part masterclass
the first one is vocabulary.
You will learn tons of vocabulary and not
just vocabulary that you never use and
you forget but the vocabulary that
natives really use every single day and
will also show you how to never forget
it.
The second reason is because of
pronunciation you will learn the way
that natives really speak not at all
like how you learned in school and the
third reason is because you will learn
the cultural context so that you will be
able to understand and laugh along with
every single joke and in addition to all
of this if you join our full Fluent with Friends course
you will never be alone in
your learning because you get to join
our global community of English learners:
the Fluency Circle.
So what are you waiting for?
You can try that all for free with our
three-part masterclass by clicking up
here or down in the description below.
Hey, if you are watching this lesson
then I would bet that you enjoy learning
English with songs right?
Well, we have this whole
playlist filled with a variety of different songs
and you are guaranteed to
find something there that
you will love living with after you
finish this lesson so to find that all
you have to do is click up here or down
description below.